nächstes Thema es geht um Sport in
Deutschland die corona-pandemie hat ja
auch dem Breitensport und den
Sportverein zugesetzt jetzt trifft auch
noch die Energiekrise den Sport kalte
Turnhallen duschen ohne Wasser auch dort
muss Energie eingespart werden es liegen
zwei Anträge vor zum Thema Sport in
Deutschland einer der Unionsfraktion
und einer der afd-fraktionen da werden
wir zu den Inhalten doch einiges in der
Debatte hören jetzt hören wir erstmal
den ersten Redner zum Auftakt Herbert
Wollmann für die SPD
die gute Nachricht von heute Nachmittag
lautet der Sport steht innerhalb weniger
Wochen zum vierten Mal auf der
Tagesordnung dieses Plenums
dies zeigt die Bedeutung des Sports auch
wenn wir heute relativ reduziert hier
vor Ort sind die Bedeutung der Sports
für Gesundheit und Soziales
Zusammenleben hat den Bundestag erreicht
und das meine Damen und Herren könnte so
weitergehen
die schlechte Nachricht dieses Name das
lautet dagegen ihr Antrag Liebe
CDU-Abgeordnete ist eigentlich
überflüssig denn sie rennen ja offene
Türen ein
ich werde das im weiteren begründen
danke Diabetes Übergewicht
Bewegungsmangel und depressive Störung
Gewissheit die Pandemie dazu beigetragen
diese Krankheiten in den Vordergrund zu
schieben denn die Pandemie wirkte wie
ein Brennglas auch schon bestehende
Defiziten
dies wurde uns durch die Pandemie nur
ein großer Deutlichkeit vor Augen
geführt viele der Probleme wie zum
Beispiel die Gewichtszunahme von oder
bei Kindern beobachten wir aber im
Grunde schon seit ca 20 Jahren
diese Gesundheitsprobleme sind nicht
durch das Virus selbst ausgelöst das
wissen wir alle sondern zum Teil durch
die notwendigen pandemie-schutzmaßnahmen
die wir ergriffen hatten um Schlimmeres
zu verhindern
nun tragen wir alle gemeinsam
Verantwortung dafür die unerwünschten
Wirkungen der pandeminas-maßnahmen
abzumildern
diese Bundesregierung das wissen Sie
eigentlich auch bei der CDU hat schon
vor Monaten mit der Planung eines
bewegungsgipfels begonnen unabhängig von
der Forderung des Gegenstands ihres
Antrages
ich kann es begonnen in diesem
Zusammenhang erinnere ich an den
präventionspolitischen Abend des deusb
im Juli wo auch ihr
gesundheitspolitischer Herr Sprecher
Tino Sorge auf dem Podium anwesend war
der hat ihn eigentlich davon berichten
können
Staatssekretärin Sabine Dittmer hat
schon damals gesagt es wird den
Bewegungs- und gesundheitsgipfel geben
sie wissen vielleicht oder sollten es
wissen am 28 September also nächste
Woche
werden wir zum ersten Mal eine
gemeinsame Sitzung des Gesundheits- und
Sportausschusses stattfinden lassen es
wird ein sehr kompetenten
Gesprächspartner geben Professor
Wohlfahrt Chefarzt für Sportmediziner
und rehabilitive Medizin an der Charité
Berlin gleichzeitig Olympia Arzt
die können daran erkennen dass die Ampel
in Verbindung von Sport und Gesundheit
die sektorenübergreifende Aufgabe schon
längst erkannt hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen kommen
wir darauf zurück warum wir den Antrag
ablehnen werden
die Wirklichkeit hat ihrer Forderung
schlicht und einfach überholt
und wir werden ihn übrigens auch
ablehnen weil davon längst bekannten
Allgemeinplätzen nur so wimmelt
der bewegungskürzel ist längst Chef in
den Sache im Innenministerium der Termin
steht fest es wird der 13 dezember
dieses Jahres sein
ja aber jetzt wissen sie es okay
es gab noch nie eine solch hochkarätig
besetzte Initiative zum Thema
Sportbewegung und Gesundheit
es werden die Ministerinnen Feder Paul
Lemke sowie Minister Lauterbach daran
teilnehmen auch das werden Sie noch
nicht wissen
neben dem DOSB mit Herrn weigert und dem
Deutschen Behindertensportverband werden
alle relevanten
steakholder angesprochen und vor Ort
sein
ja gut und das wichtigste wird sein wir
werden als Ergebnis des bewegungsgipfels
ganz konkrete Ziele und Verpflichtungen
für alle Beteiligten formulieren Sie
sehen also die von Ihnen aufgeführten
Vorschläge sind zwar gut gemeint aber
ehrlich gesagt wir brauchen als Ampel
keine Nachhilfe in Sportbewegung und
Gesundheit
nein das brauchen wir nicht ich habe
jetzt leider nur noch 30 Sekunden ich
will ja keine weiteren Creme mehr
aufreißen ich denke im Sportausschuss am
brennen wir alle für die Sache im Herzen
tragen wir den Sport alle mit uns wir
sind unheimlich kompetent wir haben
Olympiasieger wir haben sonst was in
unserem Ausstoß ich möchte eigentlich
dass die Stimmung in diesem Gremium
besser wird und
wie also
zum Schluss möchte ich noch mal eins
sagen wie wichtig Sport auch gerade für
Kinder jugendliches sehen wir daran dass
der Breitensport die Grundlage des
leistungssportes ist und der letzte sagt
sagt alles zum ersten Mal seit glaube
ich 16 Jahren hat der Deutschland Achter
das Finale bei einer Weltmeisterschaft
nicht erreicht das ist ein Zeichen dafür
dass wir für den Sport und für den
Leistungssport aber natürlich auch für
den Breitensport richtig was tun müssen
danke
Bollmann hier erster Redner für die
SPD-Fraktion der deutsche olympischen
Sportbund hat bereits im Juni ein
bewegungsgipfel gefordert die
Bundesregierung hat hier Herbert Reumann
gerade ausgeführt der plant ihn seit
Monaten die cdu/csu-fraktion fordert ihn
in ihrem Ausschuss hören wir mal Fritz
Künstler für die Union
ich finde es gut dass wir mal wieder
über den Sport debattieren denn das
glaube ich können wir gemeinsam
feststellen dass über den Sport hier im
Plenum viel zu selten gesprochen wird
von daher mag man unseren Antrag
beurteilen wie man will aber ich glaube
dass wir über Sport hier reden ist schon
Erfolg für sich denn die aktuelle der
Lage des Wortes sollte uns alle
interessieren der Sport in Deutschland
ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil unserer
Gesellschaft und unseres gesamten
Zusammenlebens ein paar Zahlen wir haben
87.600 Sportvereine in denen 23,4
Millionen Menschen engagiert sind und
man sollte nicht vergessen über 8
million sind ehrenamtlich darüber hinaus
engagiert sei es als Vorstandsmitglied
als Übungsleiter oder anderweitig nach
Berechnung des deusb sind fast 500
Millionen Arbeitsstunden die pro Jahr
ehrenamtlich geleistet wird ich finde
das ist ein Dankeschön an die
Ehrenamtlichen Wert meine Damen und
Herren
die corona-pandemie der Kollege hat
darauf hingewiesen Herr Dr Wollmann hat
den gesamten Gesellschaft vor große
Herausforderungen gestellt natürlich
auch der Sport Schule Vereine
Fitnessstudios konnten nicht mehr den
Sport treiben wie es bisher war das gibt
nicht ohne Auswirkung darüber haben wir
uns im Sportausschuss jetzt auch
mehrfach unterhalten Mitglieder
Rückgänge sind nicht in dem Umfang
entstanden wie befürchtet aber doch
gerade bei jungen Menschen sehr hoch von
daher ist es glaube ich unser
augenmerkwert dass wir da in
gegensteuern und gerade der
Bewegungsmangel bei jungen Menschen nach
Studien hat um 44 Prozent abgenommen wir
haben feststellen können dass der
Schwimmunterricht nicht mehr so
stattfinden dass es halt fast halbiert
worden und der Behindertensportverband
hat uns darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass
fast nur noch 55 Prozent der Menschen
mit Behinderung Sport treiben das sind
alles zahlen die uns nicht glücklich
schätzen und von daher müssen wir
handeln und wir sollten gemeinsam
handeln und der bewegungsgipfel der ja
nicht nur von uns gefordert wird sondern
auch von Deutschen Olympischen Sportbund
gefordert wird ist ein Instrument nicht
das Frage Instrument aber ein Instrument
dafür und wir sind froh Kollege haben
sich schon darauf hingewiesen dass die
Opposition so wirkt wir hatten schon das
Gefühl dass sie zwar angekündigt haben
aber das nichts geschah also wir haben
ja jetzt erstmals öffentlich gehört wann
dieser Gipfel stattfinden soll von daher
finde ich es gut dass diese Antrag dazu
geführt hat dass doch im
Innenministerium ein bisschen Bewegung
aufgekommen ist denn bis jetzt hat der
Sport da glaube ich noch nicht die Rolle
gespielt die der Sport eigentlich
verdient hätte von daher freuen wir uns
über den Gipfel und wir freuen dass
unser Antrag in dem Sinne Erfolg gehabt
hat
denn das hätte auch alles von früher
kommen können wir haben viel Zeit
verloren und ich glaube schon dass der
Antrag hilfreich sein kann was die
Erwartungshaltung an so ein Gipfel
angeht konzertierte Aktion bei Ihnen ja
auch oft genannt ich glaube schon wir
müssen uns ein klares Lagebild mit allen
Betroffenen machen wir müssen die
Handlungsfelder definieren der DOSB hat
Vorschläge gemacht neuen Handlungsfelder
schon mal aufgeschrieben und wir müssen
und das ist mir wie am wichtigsten auch
Lösungsansätze konkrete Lösungsansätze
erarbeiten denn wir wollen dass
Deutschland sich wieder mehr bewegt und
das ist ja auch in der Anhörung im
deutschen Sportausschuss deutlich
geworden dass wir da Nachholbedarf haben
wir hatten mal eine trimm dich Bewegung
ins in den 70er Jahren ich glaube da
konnten wir wieder ansetzen es gibt die
ersten Ideen und das sollten wir
unterstützen denn wir sind die die
Rahmenbedingungen setzen können und
deshalb müssen wir auch was tun und ich
muss Ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen als
Ampelkoalition Herr Dr Wollmann wenn sie
sagen sie brauchen keine Nachhilfe das
hätte ich als
regierungsfraktionsvertreter auch immer
gesagt aber ich glaube das ist die ganz
ehrliche Analyse denn ich glaube sie
bleiben hinter den Erwartungen schon
gewaltig zurück also wenn ich den
Koalitionsvertrag ansehe und ich da sehe
dass das eine Entwicklungsplan Sport
geben soll dass sie die
Sportinfrastruktur weiter fördern wollen
genau das Gegenteil machen Sie sie haben
die sportinfrastrukturprogramm gekürzt
sie nehmen den Geldern sie nehmen den
Kommunen die Gelder sie machen genau das
Gegenteil von dem was sie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben also
von daher bitte ich sie machen Sie ein
bisschen mehr sie die Nachhilfe ist
glaube ich angesagt und sie rühmen sich
jetzt mit einem riester-programm nach
Corona ein Neustart der kommen sollte
lediglich 25 Millionen Euro haben sie
das hinterlegt das war auf der
Haushaltsausschuss nicht mal diese
Bundesregierung die Mittel werden zwar
von 22 nach 23 fortgetragen für 23 ist
der Haushaltsansatz 0 sie machen gar
nichts obwohl sie damals angekündigt
haben das Geld wird nicht reichen wir
werden was drauflegen das muss man nur
mal durchrechnen wenn man von den 25
Millionen Euro gehen alleine fünf
Millionen für Werbemaßnahmen auf 16
Millionen werden letztendlich bei den
Sportvereinen landen das bedeutet 67
Cent Unterschied in einem deutschen
Sportverein das ist eigentlich gar
nichts das ist so ein Klax und ich würde
Sie bitten so viel müssen Sie vielleicht
im Nachhilfeunterricht dann mitnehmen
dass sie da vielleicht über ihre
Haushälter da ein wenig mehr Geld
drauflegen damit sie die Erwartungen die
im Sport da sind einfach erfüllen sie
haben also noch erheblich Luft nach oben
und wir werden sie dabei unterstützen
denn das eint uns im Sportausschuss wir
sind alle sportbegeistert die einen
können auch besser Sport treiben als die
anderen aber manche sind auch im FC
Bundestag aktiv und Beweis und ah dass
sie fußballerisches Können haben dass
beweisen sie jeden Dienstag in der
Sitzungswoche bewegen sich also bewegen
wir uns alle nutzen Sie die Möglichkeit
der hardeweg hat in der letzten Debatte
darauf hingewiesen dass es ein Lauftreff
für Abgeordnete gibt also es geht auch
für uns auf die Abgeordneten sollten uns
hier und da ein bisschen mehr bewegen
herzlichen Dank ein schönes Wochenende
[Applaus]
der Abgeordnete Philipp Krämer hat nun
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
das Wort
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren muss ja wirklich noch
als Vorbemerkung sagen ich finde die
Sportpolitik ja immer sehr angenehm weil
wir alle gemeinsam an dem Sport treiben
und generell arbeiten und das ist im
Verhältnis zu anderen Politikfeldern
echt gut und ich freue mich auch da auf
weitere Auseinandersetzung weil wir
natürlich dann doch im Kern
unterschiedliche Ansichten haben Liebe
sportpolitiker der cdu/csu-fraktion es
wird sie jetzt nicht verwundern aber ihr
Antrag bewegungsgipfel jetzt ausrichten
vom 5 juli ist eher eine Bestätigung für
die Sportpolitik der Ampel und der
Regierungskoalition denn im Juni also
schon vor Antragstellung hat
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
bereits den bewegungsgipfel ausgerufen
und jetzt dann am Montag auch terminiert
und ich glaube das ist ein gutes
vorgehen und wir werden das haben wir
eben auch gehört am 13 dezember in
ausrichten und mit der Bundes-
politischen Sportbund und
dementsprechend gehe ich davon aus dass
das auf einem guten Weg ist aber das
haben sie anscheinend auch verpasst
sowie viele Gelegenheiten auch im
Sportbereich in den letzten Jahren die
sie leider verpasst und vergeben haben
bei dem bewegungsgipfel im Dezember wird
es um die Zukunft des Sports gehen und
den Ausbau von Strukturen im
Breitensport wir legen dabei ein
besonderes Augenmerk darauf wie wir
Menschen ob weiblich männlich divers ob
jung oder alt ob Menschen mit oder ohne
Einschränkungen für Sport und Bewegung
stärker begeistern können und werden
ressortübergreifend eben über vier
Ministerien hinweg eine Gesamtstrategie
entwickeln das ist beschlossene Sache
und wir werden
dabei einen besonderen Fokus auf die
Bedürfnisse von Kindern und Jugendlichen
legen und das ist mir hier auch noch mal
sehr wichtig denn das was sie im Antrag
schreiben stimmt ja die Menschen in
Deutschland treiben weniger Sport und
Studien zeigen 44% der Kinder bewegen
sich seit der Pandemie weniger und daran
müssen wir gemeinsam über die
verschiedenen Ebenen hinweg arbeiten
aber wir haben im Blick wie stark und
wichtig der Einfluss des Sports auf die
Entwicklung von Kindern und jugendwissen
ist wir haben im Blick wie herausragend
die gesellschaftliche Bedeutung von
Sport ist wie sehr Sport den sozialen
Zusammenhalt fördert die Integration und
Inklusion vorantreibt und darum stellen
wir durch das Programm restart insgesamt
25 Millionen Euro bereit um das
Vereinsleben und die Ehrenamtlichen
Strukturen in den Vereinen nach Corona
wiederzubeleben
und genau weil wir die Kinder im Blick
haben und die ja auch besonders in der
Pandemie zurückgestreckt haben wenn es
denn um das Miteinander in Sporthallen
und auf Sportplätzen gehen haben wir
gemeinsam in der Novelle
desinfektionsschutzesschutzgesetzes
ausgeschlossen das Pandemie bedingte
Schließung von Sporthallen erfolgen
können und das ist ein gutes Zeichen für
die Menschen insbesondere die Kinder und
Jugendlichen in den Sportverein
dabei ist aber der Bedarf an Sanierungen
und Neubau sie hatten das ja auch
angesprochen gehabt und wir sprechen uns
sicherlich in jeder Rede zu Sportpolitik
an unbestritten insbesondere der Umbau
hin zu klimaneutralen und positiven
Gebäuden wird eine generationaufgabe die
gerade für finanzschwache Kommunen
wirtschaftlich schwierigen Zeiten eine
große Herausforderung darstellt dennoch
und das muss man glaube ich doch auch
noch mal deutlich machen waren die
Investitionen des Bundes für die
sportstätteninfrastruktur im Jahr 2022
auf dem höchsten Stand aller Zeiten und
von daher ist es schon verwunderlich
dass die cdu/csu-fraktion in 16 Jahren
offenbar einen Sanierungsstau anwachsen
lassen hat und deren Beseitigung in
wirtschaftlich schweren Zeiten nun der
jungen Koalition Anlassen möchte und das
ist das ist tatsächlich glaube ich auch
etwas was man unter Haushalts
Ehrlichkeit versteht wenn man denn mehr
Geld fordert in der relativ hohen Höhe
dann muss man auch deutlich machen auf
der anderen Seite wo man dieses Geld
einspart und das ist in wirtschaftlich
schweren Zeiten genau die Kunst von
Haushaltsführung
und wir wissen wir als grüne Fraktion
wissen aber dass Sport einen festen
Platz in unserer Gesellschaft hat dafür
darum muss er für alle nachhaltig
gefördert werden in diesem Jahr nehmen
wir etwa mit dem Bundesprogramm
Sportjugend Kultur die klimagerechte
Sanierung und Modernisierung kommunale
Einrichtungen in den Bereichen Sport
Jugend und kulturellen Fokus und
unterstützen hier mit 476 Millionen Euro
das wird sich möglicherweise auch im
Haushaltsverfahren wir werden Debatten
führen noch mal etwas ausbauen können
und mit dem Programm werden Projekte
unterstützt die vorbildhaft Hinsicht
hinsichtlich ihrer Nachhaltigkeit und
Barrierefreiheit sind und ein
Schwerpunkt liegt dabei auf Sportstätten
und insbesondere Schwimmbädern da hier
eben ein besonderer Sanierungsbedarf
existiert
und ich freue mich dass wir etwa mit
Special Olympics 2023 den World Games
als auch der Euro 2024 und vielleicht
sogar in einigen Jahren mit Olympischen
und Paralympischen Spielen in den
nächsten Jahren spannende Sport
Großveranstaltungen in Deutschland haben
werden wichtig ist mir aber dass diese
Veranstaltung auch immer mit einer
Unterstützung des Breitensports
einhergehen müssen das bedeutet dass
einerseits die vielen Vereine und
aktiven in den Vorbereitung einbezogen
werden das andererseits aber auch nicht
nur Investitionen in den Spitzensport
sondern eben auch in die vielen
Sportstätten des Breitensports in den
Kommunen mitgedacht werden Sport
Großveranstaltung als Motor des gesamten
Sports zu verstehen das könnte auch zu
mehr Akzeptanz in der breiten
Gesellschaft führen Liebe Union wie Sie
sehen wir haben das Problem im Blick wir
werden der aktuellen Entwicklung
entgegensteuern und versäumt es aufholen
und wir möchten die Bedingungen für alle
Sporttreibenden in Deutschland
verbessern und darum werden wir die
Mittel bereitstellen um den Sport und
auch die Menschen im Ehrenamt die ihn
tragen zu unterstützen der
bewegungsgipfel wird im Dezember aber
angekündigt stattfinden und wir kämpfen
an vielen Stellen gemeinsam mit
Verbänden Organisationen Vereinen aber
eben auch mit der Opposition gemeinsam
das ist mir wie gesagt in dem Bereich
auch noch mal sehr wichtig um die
Sportbedingungen in diesem Land zu
verbessern sie können uns dabei gerne
unterstützen Ihren Antrag im konkreten
benötigen wir dafür aber nicht vielen
Dank
Creme war das für die Fraktion Bündnis
für 90 die Grünen ja die Bundesregierung
stellt für den Neustart des Vereins und
Breitensports nach der corona-pandemie
25 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung
[Applaus]
die AFD hat hier auch einen Antrag zur
Debatte vorgelegt und fordert bessere
Rahmen und Förderbedingungen hören wir
für die AFD Jörn König
diesen Antrag jetzt so häufig im Plenum
ist und freuen uns darüber dass wir wie
gesagt darüber heute mal reden können
aber eines steht mal fest die Union hat
ein schlechtes Gewissen die
unionsgeführte Regierung hat in den
pandemiejahren die Grundrechte ohne
Datengrundlage eingeschränkt sie haben
damit auch massiv das Sport treiben und
auch den Schulsport verhindert ich
zitiere den corona-expertenrat eine
Ermächtigung des Gesundheitsministeriums
um von anderen Gesetzen abzuweichen ist
verfassungswidrig gestern hatten wir von
Ihnen die beiden Anträge im Plenum mit
den pandemiebedingten lernrückständen
die eigentlich lernrückstände durch
verfassungswidriger Maßnahmen hätten
heißen müssen heute nun wollen sie
Deutschland durch Sport gesünder machen
jedenfalls schreiben Sie das in ihren
antragstitel wie soll das gehen es soll
ein sogenannter bewegungsgipfel finden
wie gesagt sie die Union sie werden
geplagt von schlechtem Gewissen jetzt
kommen sie mit lauter Anträgen ins
Plenum um mir Versagen in der
corona-maßnahmen Zeit zu reparieren Ihr
ex-gesundheitsminister
Jens Spahn hat sogar ein Buch
geschrieben über seine ich zitiere die
Welt zahlreichen Fehler in der Pandemie
das vermeidbare Versagen der Union ist
zu kritisieren und zu verdammen die
Kurskorrektur zur Reparatur ist
ausdrücklich zu begrüßen denn fehlendes
Vermögen zur Umkehr auch bei völligem
Versagen das war das Hauptmerkmal
während der lähmenden merkelzeit
[Applaus]
dem Antrag bewegungsgipfel jetzt
ausrichten werden wir zustimmen denn er
ist wie gesagt der richtige Versuch die
inzwischen Jahrzehnte lange
Vernachlässigung des Sports zu
reparieren
endlich endlich hat auch das
Innenministerium bestätigt dass ein
bewegungsgipfel im Dezember stattfinden
wird viel besser aber und viel
weitreichender als die Reparatur mit
lauter Einzelmaßnahmen wie die Union es
im Antrag vorschlägt wäre jedoch eine
umfassende Stärkung des
gesellschaftlichen Stellenwerts des
Sports in Deutschland wäre Sport treiben
so angesagt wie zum Beispiel den 80er
oder 90er Jahren dann hätten wir viele
der heutigen Probleme erst gar nicht
sportstabilisiert den Bewegungsapparat
bei Krankheiten wie knochenschonend
Übergewicht Herz-Kreislauf oder Diabetes
vor
Gesundheitsvorsorge durch Sport wird
immer wichtiger denn der
Altersdurchschnitt der deutschen steigt
im demografischen Wandel
schätzungen zufolge können mit einem
investierten Euro in den Sport 3 Euro
bei den Gesundheitskosten gespart werden
sportliche Aktivitäten besonders im
Sportverein sind gut für die
Persönlichkeitsentwicklung gerade junger
Menschen
dabei werden neben grundlegenden
kulturellen Werten auch klassische
Tugenden wie Geradlinigkeit
Gerechtigkeitssinn Ehrlichkeit Disziplin
Pünktlichkeit Ordnungssinn Fleiß und
Pflichtbewusstsein vermittelt
Mannschaftssportarten sind ideal
geeignet um ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl zu
entwickeln
Aktivitäten in Sportvereinen verbinden
Menschen unterschiedlichster sozialer
oder auch ethnischer Herkunft
nichts nichts einzuseher wie gemeinsame
Aufgaben Ziele und Erfolge und genau
deshalb hat die afd-fraktion einen
Antrag mit genau diesem Titel Stärkung
des gesellschaftlichen Stellenwerts des
Sports beigestellt er ist Teil unserer
antragsserie Sportnation Deutschland in
der wir Breite und umfassende Vorschläge
für eine Wiedergeburt des fast tot
gesparten Sports vorlegen werden
wie Sportpolitik also richtig geht
können Sie bei der Alternative für
Deutschland lernen allein in dieser
Wahlperiode die gerade mal ein Jahr alt
ist haben wir insgesamt 14 sportanträge
eingebracht schreiben Sie einfach bei
uns ab da können Sie noch was lernen
sportfrei und vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
Björn König war das für die afd-fraktion
nächster Redner hier in der Debatte zum
Thema Sportpolitik ist der Abgeordnete
Philipp hartewich für die FDP-Fraktion
erster sportpolitische Sprecher
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Sportfreunde sportliche Betätigung eines
jeden Einzelnen kann ganz
unterschiedlich aussehen ob als Einzel
oder Mannschaftssport ob organisiert im
Verein oder bei der gemeinsamen
Feierabend Runde ob in Sporthallen
draußen auf Anlagen oder im Wald Sport
ist der Spaß einer Bewegung an neuen
Herausforderungen und manchmal auch die
Begeisterung am Wettkampf Sport in
seiner ganzen Vielfalt und Faszination
fördert Gesundheit Wohlbefinden und
Zusammenhalt er hat große Bedeutung für
alle Generationen in unserem Land
die vergangenen Jahre waren für den
Sport oder insbesondere den
corona-bedingten Einschränkungen
besonders hart und die Situation ist
auch im Hinblick auf die aktuelle
Energie Situation sehr belastend mit den
aktuellen Erkenntnissen auch im
Rückblick auf die vergangenen
zweieinhalb Jahre
muss aber auch die Politik so ehrlich
sein und sagen
viele der sportbezogene Maßnahmen waren
falsch und kontraproduktiv
sportstättenschließungen waren den
letzten beiden Wintern das Schlimmste
mit was man machen konnte die
Auswirkungen auch davon war sind immens
und werden uns noch lange beschäftigen
und daher ist umso wichtiger jetzt noch
mal zu betonen die Bundesländer können
keine sportstättenschließungen aufgrund
von Corona mehr vornehmen auch hier hat
die Koalition Block eingeschlagen und
das ganz wichtig für den Sport und es
ein wichtiges Signal alle Vereine in
diesem Land
Sport ist hinsichtlich seiner positiven
Auswirkungen ein echte
Querschnittsmaterie daher haben sie
Kollege Künstler auch zu Recht in ihrem
Antrag aber auch in der Rede
thematisiert dass wir das auch als
querschnitts-
der für dezember geplante
bewegungsgipfel soll mehr als nur ein
gutes und wichtiges Signal für mehr
Bewegung in Deutschland sein wir werden
Ressort übergreifend mit dem Ministerien
die Maßnahmen auch zur Förderung eines
aktiven Lebens in der Bevölkerung
abstimmen aber Kollege Bollmann hat es
auch zutreffend gesagt wir werden es
bereits nächste Woche als Sportausschuss
gemeinsam mit dem mit dem
Gesundheitsausschuss austauschen und da
freue ich mich auch schon auf den
Austausch und auch auf die Expertise
unseres gemeinsamen Sachverständigen
Professor Wohlfahrt
Tragpfeiler einer vitalen Gesellschaft
ist aber auch vor allem der organisierte
Sport der organisierte Sport ist auch
für mehr Bewegung in Deutschland starker
Verbündeter in jeder Gemeinde findet
sich mindestens einer der 85.000
Sportvereine der lokale Sportverein ist
Anlaufpunkt für nach Gemeinschaft und
Bewegung suchende Menschen jeden Alters
denn dass ich so viele Menschen oder den
23 Millionen Mitgliedern Sportvereinen
sportlich betätigen können liegt
insbesondere aber auch an den
Ehrenamtlichen vor Ort ob Trainer Platz
war Pfarrer für Auswärtsspiele
camporganisator oder der Vorstandsarbeit
sie alle machen den Vereinssport erst so
richtig möglich Ihnen euch gilt es zu
danken wir wissen als Koalition um die
um den Wert des Ehrenamts auch dabei
Verstehens als gemeinsame Aufgabe aber
auch die Rahmenbedingungen im Ehrenamt
zu verbessern denn ihr bringt
Deutschland erst rechtlichen Bewegung
es gibt aber noch einen anderen großen
Bereich der eine Debatte um Sport und
Bewegung oft zu kurz kommt und der auch
insbesondere in den letzten Jahren
besonders transaliert wurde und das ist
die gesamte Fitnessbranche nicht nur im
Vereinssport sondern auch in den
tausenden Fitnessstudios gibt es teils
rund um die Ohr beste Bedingungen für
körperliche Bewegung in den rund 10
Millionen Mitgliedern Fitnessstudios in
Deutschland stehen meist
mittelständische studioinhaber Personal
Trainer Hersteller modernster Geräte für
vielfältigen und individuellen
Fitnesssport die ganze Branche spielt
sprüht vor Innovationen in individuellen
Terminen und Kursangeboten wird in den
Studios nicht nur bei Verletzungen oder
körperlichen Leiden rehabilitiert
fitnessstudiosen auch für Millionen
Menschen wichtige Alltagsbegleiter für
körperliches und mentales Wohlbefinden
und letztlich weitere tragende Säule in
der Gesundheitsprävention
Sportvereine und fitnessbranchen
zusammen Verbündete und wichtige Partner
bei unseren gemeinsamen Anliegen wie
auch andere sind sie derzeit durch die
aktuellen Energiepreise erheblich
belastet und ich möchte auch an uns in
diesem Haus an der Stelle noch mal
appellieren bei weiteren möglichen
Maßnahmen bei den Diskussionen darüber
auch insbesondere die Lage des Sports
stärker zu berücksichtigen denn der
Sport stärkt auch in Krisenzeiten
zum Abschluss noch zwei Bemerkungen das
erste passend zum heutigen beactive day
als Start der europäischen Woche des
Sports der Hinweise an vielen Orten auch
in den kommenden Tagen spezielle
Mitmachangebote auch an öffentlichen
Plätzen stattfinden eine gute
Gelegenheit um zusammenzukommen
vielleicht eine neue Sportart zu finden
und zuletzt nach der Appell an uns
selbst schützen wir den Sport stärken
wir den Sport und gehen wir selbst
sportlich als Vorbilder voran vielen
Dank
ja heute beginnt tatsächlich die
europäische Woche des Sports von heute
bis zum 30 September eine jährlich
stattfindende Kampagne der Europäischen
Kommission
die Active für lautet hier das Motto
Europa wir weit nehmen 40 Länder
und Initiativen teil und hier in
Deutschland koordiniert dass der
deutsche Turnerbund
CDU CSU offenbar geholfen über die
Ausrichtung des Sports tatsächlich mal
ernsthaft nachzudenken in ihrem Antrag
steht viel Richtiges auch manches was
die Linke seit Jahren gefordert hat
deshalb werden wir dem Antrag auch
zustimmen der bewegungsgipfel soll nun
wohl endlich am 13 dezember dieses
Jahres stattfinden und ich habe gehört
dass die Vorbereitung dafür in
Hinterzimmern bereits im Gange sind ich
meine es gibt gute Gründe nicht nur die
koalitionsfraktion sondern den gesamten
Sportausschuss an diesem Prozess
inhaltlich zu beteiligen denn die
aktuellen Probleme und Herausforderungen
im Sport können wir nur gemeinsam
bewältigen
im Koalitionsvertrag gibt es eine Reihe
von Ankündigung und Versprechungen im
Bereich des Sports die wir als LINKE
unterstützen nur klar ist auch das was
die Ampel bislang geliefert hat ist
einfach zu wenig
grund dafür sind mitnichten nur
weltpolitischer Entwicklungen hier geht
es auch um hausgemachtes Versagen aus
Sicht der Linken darf es nicht wieder
passieren dass wie schon während der
corona-pandemie flächendeckend
Sportstätten und insbesondere
Schwimmbäder geschlossen werden dass der
Sport in den bisherigen drei
entlastungspaketen oder Päckchen muss
man ja sagen keine Rolle spielt ist ein
Armutszeugnis für diese Bundesregierung
und ohne den Antrag der Linken das Thema
Energiekrise endlich auf die
Tagesordnung des Sportausschusses zu
setzen würde sich die Koalition gern
weiter um diese gravierenden Probleme
herumdrücken jetzt steht das Thema am 9
November auf der Tagesordnung im übrigen
rechnen sich jetzt auch die viel zu
gering Investitionen in die energetische
Sanierung bei den Sportstätten der Bund
muss hier endlich ein wirksamen Beitrag
mit mindestens einer Milliarde Euro pro
Jahr in den kommenden zehn Jahren
leisten
die Vorschläge der Linken dazu liegen
auf dem Tisch kurz noch zum Programm
restart Sport nach corona-kollege
Günzler hat es angesprochen die dafür
vorgesehenen Mittel in Höhe von 25
Millionen Euro werden definitiv nicht
ausreichen das ist knapp ein Euro pro
Mitglied im DOSB das ist zu wenig
und ich sage auch der bewegungsgipfel im
Kanzleramt darf keine
Alibi-Veranstaltung bleiben wir erwarten
dort verbindliche Zusagen zur
Unterstützung des organisierten Sports
in den aktuellen Krisenzeiten
und mein CSU-Kollege Stefan Mayer hat im
Sportausschuss gefragt ob denn die von
Herrn Habig angekündigten Hilfen für
kleine Unternehmen auch für die
Sportvereine gelten eine Antwort der
Regierung hat er nicht bekommen der
Antrag von cdu/csu greift wie eingangs
gesagt viele Punkte auf die wir seit
langem fordern deshalb haben wir kein
Problem damit einem vernünftigen
Vorschlag der Union zuzustimmen
vielleicht wäre es ganz sinnvoll letzter
Satz wenn auch die Union endlich mal
ihre Verweigerungshaltung aufgeben würde
und einem der vielen guten Anträge der
Linken auch mal zustimmt
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun die
Kollegin Bettina Luke das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die Opposition hat uns in
ihren Anträgen deutlich skizziert welche
Probleme sie momentan in der
Sportpolitik dieses Landes sieht während
sie noch Anträge schreiben sind wir
längst an der Lösung der Probleme die
Aussage dürfte Ihnen bereits bekannt
vorkommen natürlich gibt es
Herausforderungen die noch nicht gelöst
sind denn wir leben offenkundig in
schwierigen Zeiten
zwischen dem Beschluss des
Koalitionsvertrages und dem heutigen
plenarbeitrag hat sich vieles verändert
und klar wir wollen sicherlich an der
ein oder anderen Stelle weiter sein
stellen uns aber der Realität der
Kollege Wollmann und der Kollege Krämer
haben bereits ausgeführt wie es sich mit
den bewegungsgipfel verhält hier setzen
wir etwas um und zwar gemeinsam mit der
Bundesregierung und den Ländern doch es
gibt auch vieles gutes auf das wir heute
stolz sein können im nächsten Jahr
begrüßen wir hier in Berlin eines der
größten Sportfeste der Welt die Special
Olympics work Games sind mit 7000
Athleten und Athleten mit 20.000
wollenteers und Internet zu allen
Delegationen hier die wir in 216
hostones empfangen werden
schon in diesem Jahr haben wir mit den
European Championships in München eine
Sportveranstaltung von internationaler
Bedeutung hier zu Gast gehabt neuen
Sportarten mit
4.000 Athletinnen und Athleten aus mehr
als 50 Ländern 1,4 Millionen
Sportbegeisterte waren im Publikum waren
in den Stadien und erzeugten eine extrem
motivierende Atmosphäre ich finde das
ist eine großartige Bilanz die sich
sehen lassen kann
[Applaus]
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
European Championships haben weit über
die Stadien und die Wettkampfstätten
hinausgewirkt
27,1 Millionen Menschen haben sich
allein an der ARD die Wettkämpfe
angeschaut Athletinnen wie Malaika
sind für noch mehr Menschen ein Vorbild
geworden besonders für Kinder und
Jugendliche die jetzt davon träumen an
großen Sportwettkämpfen teilnehmen zu
können und vielleicht sogar eines Tages
auf einem Treppchen stehen zu dürfen ein
sportbegeisterter Vater erzählte mir
kürzlich in München von genau dieser
Vorbildfunktion des Spitzensports
nachdem die ganze Familie Leichtathletik
im Fernsehen geschaut hat übte der Sohn
gleich er sprang mit Anlauf und viel
Karacho aufs Sofa
so entsteht eine Dynamik in der
Leistungs- und Spitzensport
zusammenspielt wenn unsere
Spitzensportlerinnen und Spitzensportler
erfolgreich sind da motiviert das unsere
Nachwuchs ebenfalls aktiv zu werden und
je mehr Kinder und Jugendliche Sport
treiben desto besser steht das um die
Zukunft unserer Leistungskader in 5 in
10 oder 15 Jahren die Breite braucht die
Spitze unter Spitzensport braucht den
Breitensport
deshalb arbeiten wir daran auch in der
Breite bessere Voraussetzungen zu
schaffen die Kollegen sind bereits auf
das Programm restart Sport eingegangen
mit dem wir die Vereine bei der
Wiederaufnahme von Aktivitäten nach zwei
Jahren corona-pandemie aktiv
unterstützen wollen denn es muss wieder
attraktiver sein Kinder und Jugendliche
in den Vereinen zu trainieren klar weil
uns die sportliche Betätigung der
jüngeren am Herzen liegt aber auch weil
hier Inklusion und Integration gelebt
werden und wir so auch neue Talente
entdecken können die in absehbarer Zeit
paralympische oder olympische Weltspitze
erreichen können
auch in den Schulen müssen wir Kinder
und Jugendliche wieder mehr in Bewegung
bringen auch durch eine intensivere
Zusammenarbeit der Schulen der
Sportvereine und der Verbände gerade die
Schulen bieten eine Möglichkeit Kinder
und Jugendliche mit Sportarten in
Kontakt zu bringen die in den Medien
leider weniger häufiger präsent sind
hier ist das Ganztagsschulkonzept das in
vielen Ländern verfolgt wird eine Chance
so können wir in allen olympischen und
nicht olympischen Sportarten eine
breitere Basis
aufbauen gerade im Bereich der
Jugendlichen in diesem Zusammenhang ist
mir eine Sache noch ganz besonders
wichtig neben den vielen wunderbaren
Sportarten die man ausüben und die man
probieren kann gibt es eine Fähigkeit
die Kinder alle Kinder aus meiner Sicht
erlernen müssen das ist das Schwimmen
wer als Kind schwimmen lernt erfährt
dass Motivation Fleiß und Ausdauer sich
lohnen dass es etwas bringt an Dingen
dran zu bleiben auch wenn es manchmal
schwierig ist und wer schwimmen gelernt
hat kann später Leben retten sein
eigenes aber auch vielleicht das andere
Menschen
die deutsche Lebensrettungsgesellschaft
und andere Vereine der Wasserrettung
haben seit Beginn der Pandemie mit
Problemen zu kämpfen gehabt auch weil
angehende schrettungsschwimmerinnen und
Rettungsschwimmer nicht so ausgebildet
werden konnten dies trifft gleichzeitig
auf den Umstand dass viele Kinder nicht
an Schwimmkursen teilnehmen konnten und
dies pandemiebedingt einen Rückstand
entstanden ist und nachgeholt werden
muss darum müssen wir jetzt zusammen mit
den Kommunen den Schwimmverein
sicherstellen dass im Zuge der
Energiekrise zumindest die Schwimmbäder
geöffnet bleiben denn wir müssen darauf
bestehen dass jedes Kind in Deutschland
ob mit oder ohne Behinderung Zugang zu
einem Schwimmkurs hat
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen Sport
macht uns stärker Sport bringt uns
zusammen gerade in Zeiten wie diesen
können wir darauf nicht verzichten den
gesellschaftlichen den gesundheitlichen
und den jugendpolitischen Wert des
Sports zu schätzen lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern im
Bundesinnenministerium in den Ländern in
den Kommunen in den Sportverbänden und
Vereinen systematisch und zielorientiert
und nicht schnell um kopflos arbeiten
damit der Sport in Deutschland Spitze
bleibt vielen Dank
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun der
Kollege Jens Lehmann das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
mein Herz gehört im Sport und so viele
andere Menschen treibe ich regelmäßig
Sport um fit zu bleiben und um das
körperliche Wohlbefinden zu stärken aber
ich mache mir große Sorgen um die
Sportnation Deutschland nicht nur sind
seit Jahren die Medaillenausbeute bei
Olympischen Spielen obwohl die Anzahl
der Wettbewerbe steigt auch der
Breitensport leidet
2021 hatten wir knapp 23,4 Millionen
Mitgliedern Sportverein den gleichen
Wert hatten wir zum Zeitpunkt meines
zweiten Olympiasiegers im Jahr 2000
bis 2020 ruft sie Mitgliederzahl stetig
weiter bis zur Rekordzahl von über 24,2
Millionen Vereinsmitgliedern
wir sind also durch die corona-pandemie
um über 20 Jahre zurückgeworfen worden
das ist ein trauriger Trend
den wir schnellstens gegensteuern müssen
als Union haben wir mit den
corona-hilfen einen wichtigen Beitrag
geleistet
dank dieser Hilfen sind nur eine Million
Sportfreunde aus dem Verein ausgetreten
ohne diese Maßnahmen werden es
vermutlich deutlich mehr gewesen und
vermutlich würde es auch viele
profisportvereine und liegen nicht mehr
geben
Bewegungsmangel
ist auch in vielen Bereichen der
Gesellschaft ein immer größer werdendes
Problem mit all seinen im Antrag
beschriebenen Folgen
was verschiedene Ursachen hat angefangen
von zu wenig angebotenen Kitas und
Schulen über Barrierefreiheit an
Sportstätten den Föderalismus bis hin zu
Corona und zur aktuellen Energiekrise
deshalb braucht es jetzt eine
bewegungsgipfel mit allen Beteiligten
Ebenen und Gruppen nachdem wir im
Frühjahr diesen Antrag eingebracht haben
und Ihnen heute zur Abstimmung stellen
ist der Ampel überraschenderweise drei
Tage vor der heutigen Abstimmung
zufällig und natürlich vollkommen
losgelöst von unserem Antrag faktisch
das gleiche eingefallen
uns jedoch geht es um die Sache
und wenn Sie demnächst wieder keine Idee
haben wir helfen gerne
[Applaus]
als Union begrüßen wir grundsätzlich
ihre Bereitschaft zur Ausrichtung eines
bewegungsgipfels aber im Dezember kommt
er einfach viel zu spät er muss jetzt
kommen
denn die Vereine und alle Sportler
brauchen angesichts der explodierenden
Energiekosten keine Belehrung sie
brauchen jetzt Perspektiven für die
kommenden Monate und nicht erst im
Winter ja die Kollegen anstatt Spartipps
wie jede Kilowattstunde zählt zu geben
sparen Sie sich lieber den Atomausstieg
bis Ende Ende diesen Jahres und
schließen schieben Sie den in Richtung
2024 und bis dahin stabile und
preiswerte Energieversorgung für unsere
Sportnation und Industrienationen zu
schaffen Gesellschaft Industrie und
Sportvereine werden es Ihnen
gleichermaßen danken
Werte Kollegen der an der Fraktion
halten sie nicht an der B-Variante
unseres Antrages fest sondern stimmen
Sie doch gleich dem Original zu jetzt
wie es in unserem Antrag heißt jetzt
bewegen sich die Leute noch draußen
schauen Sie doch einfach mal raus auf
die reichstagswiesen das wird gerade der
Berlin-Marathon vorbereitet
und wenn ich ihre rhetorischen Klimmzüge
sehe um irgendeine Begründung zu finden
unseren Antrag abzulehnen da ist es
einfach nur traurig für den Sport in
Deutschland auf diesem bewegungskita
können Sie beispielsweise erklären
warum sie den investitionspakt
Sportstätten auslaufen lassen sie
stellen keine Haushaltsmittel dafür
bereit obwohl sie im Koalitionsvertrag
ankündigen Zitat eine offensive für
Investitionen in Sportstätten von
Kommunen und Vereinen ausweiten zu
wollen Zitat Ende stattdessen beenden
Sie die von der Union eingebrachte
sportstättenförderung
um mal eine Zahl zu nennen der
Sanierungsstau bei kommunalen
Sportstätten beträgt laut DOSB und 31
Milliarden Euro
wenn Sie es ernst meinen mit dem Sport
in Deutschland wenn Sie wollen dass Sie
Bevölkerung Sport treibt sich in
Vereinen engagiert sich fit hält
gesünder lebt dann haben Sie jetzt die
Möglichkeit dazu meine Damen und Herren
stimmen Sie unserem Antrag zu
und lassen sie gemeinsam jetzt den Sport
in Deutschland analysieren vorantreiben
und verbessern machen wir gemeinsam den
Sport wieder attraktiv für die Menschen
in Deutschland unser Antrag ist
schließlich ganz in ihrem Sinne im
Koalitionsvertrag haben sie vereinbart
Zitat dass Ehrenamt zu fördern weil es
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
stärkt Zitat Ende und betonen dabei die
besondere Rolle des Sports
und sie kündigen eine Entwicklungsplan
Sport an bislang haben wir davon noch
nicht viel gesehen aber glücklicherweise
können wir alle bei Zustimmung zu
unserem Antrag den Auftakt zu diesen
Entwicklungsplan Sport machen indem wir
ein umfassendes Lagebild erstellen
stimmen Sie also unseren Antrag zu dann
setzen sie einen Teil ihren
Koalitionsvertrages um danke
Jens Lehmann war das letzte Redner hier
zu diesem Tagesordnungspunkt jetzt wird
abgestimmt über die beiden Anträge wir
hören immer die
bundestagsviz-präsidentin Petra Pauls zu
dem Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu mit
dem Titel
bewegungsgipfel jetzt ausrichten
Deutschland durch Sport gesünder machen
der Ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
3.588 den Antrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
2560 abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
der koalitionsfraktion gegen die Stimmen
der Fraktion der cdu/csu der
afd-fraktion und der Fraktionen die
Linke angenommen
Tagesordnungspunkt 33 damit ist der
Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion abgelehnt sie hat ja
unter anderem einen bewegungsgipfel
gefordert da haben Redner der Koalition
gesagt der sei ja nun geplant am 13
dezember in diesem Jahr jetzt die
Abstimmung über den afd-antrag in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
3.587 den Antrag der Fraktion der AFD
auf Drucksache
2363 abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich niemand die
Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den Stimmen
der koalitionsfraktion der Fraktionen
der cdu/csu und die Linke gegen die
Stimmen der afd-fraktion angenommen also
das heißt im Umkehrschluss auch hier
wieder alle Fraktionen außer der Linken
haben außer der AFD haben den Antrag der
AFD abgelehnt der hat hier also auch
keine Mehrheit gefunden das hat sich ja
aus der Debatte heraus schon
abgezeichnet so zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt das dominierende
Thema im Bundestag in dieser Woche das
war tatsächlich und ist tatsächlich die
steigenden Energiepreise und die
Belastungen für Verbraucher aber auch
für Unternehmen
das belastet viele Haushalte in
Deutschland an einer Stelle soll es für
Mieter und MieterInnen nun vor allem
Entlastung geben der Bundestag berät
nämlich jetzt in diesem nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt über den Entwurf des
sogenannten
Kohlendioxid Kosten aufteilungsgesetzes
so heißt es wirklich der Entwurf der
sieht nämlich vor dass ich Mieter und
Vermieterseite die CO2 Kosten bei den
Heizkosten künftig teilen sollen es gibt
ein Stufenmodell dazu werden wir einiges
noch in der Aussprache
erfahren das ist die erste Lesung zu
diesem Gesetzentwurf und die erste
Rednerin kommt aus den Reihen der
Bundesregierung das ist Kanzel
kiesel-tepe für die SPD die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin im
Bauministerium
Klimaschutz im Gebäudebereich ist nicht
nur eine technische Frage sondern sie
ist zuallererst eine soziale Frage und
wie diese große Aufgabe zu lösen ist
zeigt das Kohlendioxid Kosten
aufteilungsgesetz
bisher tragen die Mieterinnen und Mieter
den CO2-Preis alleine dass das nicht so
bleiben kann haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart hier räumen
wir ein Konstruktionsfehler ab den die
Union in der letzten Legislatur
verschuldet hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Ampel haben wir vereinbart ein
Stufenmodell für die Umlage des
co2-preises einzuführen eine faire
Lösung zu finden war viel Arbeit vielen
Dank an alle Beteiligten Ampel
Ressourcen
wir haben den Zeitplan eingehalten wir
haben am 25 Mai diesen Jahres dieses
Gesetz in der Bundesregierung
beschlossen den wir heute hier in erster
Lesung beraten
mit dem vorgesehenen Stufenmodell werden
einerseits Mieterinnen und Mieter
entlastet und weiterhin zu sparsamen
Heizverhalten angereizt auf der anderen
Seite gilt für Vermieterinnen und
Vermieter
Anreize zu schaffen in Energieeffizienz
ihrer Gebäude zu investieren und damit
kann die seit 2021 erhobene CO2-Preis
bei Wärme endlich seine klimapolitische
Lenkungswirkung auch entfalten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Wirkung wird kurzfristig durch die
Folgen des völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskriegs Russlands überdeckt
werden die Krise hat massive
Auswirkungen auf unsere
Energieversorgung und die Energiekosten
doch wir müssen langfristig denken wir
dürfen gar nicht erst erpressbar sein
von Despoten wie Putin auch hierfür
liefert das Gesetz einen Beitrag
mit dem
co2-kostenaufteilungsgesetz wollen wir
eine faire Aufteilung der Kosten
zwischen mietenden und vermietenden
schaffen die Verantwortung darf nicht
einseitig auf den Schultern der
Mieterinnen und Mieter abgeladen werden
das Stufenmodell für Wohngebäude knüpft
an den CO2-Ausstoß des vermieteten
Gebäudes an je niedriger die
energetische Qualität eines Gebäudes ist
umso größer ist der Anteil der
Vermieterin bzw das Vermieters und umso
kleiner ist der Anteil der Mieterinnen
und Mieter an den co2-
die Umsetzung kann ohne größeren Aufwand
im Rahmen der Heizkostenabrechnung
erfolgen Vermieterinnen und Vermieter
werden mit der brennstoffrechnung alle
für die Berechnung erforderlichen Daten
an die Hand gegeben es ist eine
bürokratiearme Lösung für einen sehr
komplexen Sachverhalt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Gesetz soll am ersten Januar 2023 in
Kraft treten daran halten wir fest
gleichzeitig war uns aber auch klar in
der aktuellen Situation sind weitere
Energiepreissteigerungen zu verhindern
wir wollen auch kein Öl ins Feuer gießen
und deshalb haben wir im dritten
Entlastungspaket die Anhebung des
co2-preises verschoben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen darüber
hinaus bringen wir weitere Maßnahmen zur
Entlastung bei den
Heizungs- und bei den Heizkosten auf den
Weg wir zahlen einen zweiten
Heizkostenzuschuss und führen in
Rekordzeit eine wohngeldreform mit
historischem Maßstab durch
[Applaus]
wir wollen nämlich den Menschen mit
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen schnell
und zielgenau unterstützen denn sie sind
es die besonders stark von den
steigenden Energiepreisen betroffen sind
und da möchten wir unterstützend
eingreifen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
ja daher hat die Bundesregierung hier
diesen Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt seitdem
ersten Januar 2021 wird ja in
Deutschland ein CO2-Preis fällig
beispielsweise auf Heizöl Erdgas Benzin
oder Diesel dadurch erhöhen sich auch
die Energiekosten für Mieter nach der
aktuellen Rechtslage können die
Heizkosten inklusive der darin
enthaltenen CO2 kosten ja komplett auf
die Mieter umgelegt werden das soll sich
ändern
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich will das sperrige Wort gar nicht
verwenden es soll eine faire Aufteilung
der
co2-kosten seine so wie es uns die Ampel
glauben machen aber was heißt von fair
und gerecht in diesem Zusammenhang ich
glaube an dieser Stelle müssen Sie Ihren
Gesetzentwurf selber noch mal genau
lesen man sollte nicht damit beginnen
Mieterinnen und Mieter gegen Vermieter
auszuspielen denn es gibt nicht die eine
übermächtige Seite und es gibt nicht den
einen den Guten und den anderen den
bösen ich erlaube mir zu darauf hin zu
wie Eisen dass zwei Drittel der
Mietwohnungen in privater